obviously right now i've i've not been
watching anything at all because i've
been just watching the league of legends
about it yeah so yeah that's why i'm
very tired today yeah i had four hours
of sleep because i've been watching
league of legends yeah really good this
year sounds like your guys problem yeah
i would talk about it
i know joey's not interested it's been
amazing
basically it's been one of the most
hypeles years in group stage i feel like
i hear that every fight
every year it's like this one behind the
scenes well they told you league of
legends is probably the only esport i
try to keep up with at least for the
worlds um it is really entertaining and
uh i'm sure it is if i i'm sure if i
like understood the rules i i think i'd
really get into it as well because i
like watching esports stuff but what i
actually enjoy about worlds specifically
world is that you get i get the same
feeling from worlds as i get watching
like say the world cup or something
right where like even even in the
smaller stages you have like really
small regions and you have like regions
that are like across the world and even
though you have like certain countries
in certain regions that are stronger
than others
like it's it still feels like a global
event where you see fans from all over
the world especially when we had a crowd
you know just like cheering for even
like teams that are not so well known
that are like up-and-coming regions and
i really
like i love that in sporting events when
it's when it's not just like one kind of
country but it's like a global kind of
event well but that's what i mean right
it's like i feel
like league for me would be like any
other sport that i just don't know the
rules of like i feel like once you teach
me the rules of like what's going on
like how you know what's a good play
what's the whole problem is you need to
learn how to play league yeah yeah right
but i don't want to do that yeah 100
yeah it's like you know it's it's like
again like learning any sport right it's
like
once you know the rules i think it you
can have a really fun time of just
watching it because watching and playing
is totally different yeah because that
that's the reason i got into league as
an esport as opposed to like maybe like
i i remember trying to get into the
overwatch esports scene [ __ ] me and oh
my god like the game aside which i don't
think is as good of a spectator sport as
say league or something like i remember
uh i went to an event with uh with our
mates and i found out that you know they
had teams from like different cities
from across the world right yeah yeah
it's really upset yeah yeah yeah and
they were like oh my god they have a
team from london i can't remember what
the exact name was spitfire london
spitfire they had a team from london
spitfire i was like great we've got some
representation for the uk and london and
i remember the team walks out and
everyone is korean and i'm just like
what
why would you lie to me like this why
would you lie to me i'm really confused
i didn't understand it but it's like a
franchise model right it's kind of like
you know like football teams where yeah
you sell the slot to whoever does it but
they have so i guess there was no
londoner who was good that wasn't
not a single londoner to my knowledge
the way that overwatch had done it is
that they had these team names decided
yeah that you could buy in and you would
give i don't know if you could choose
but yeah it kind of ruined it because
you know as much as you know i'm you
know league of legends has so many
you're allowed to bring in foreign
imports yeah um but there's like a
maximum cap to how many people you can
import from other countries you know if
you're rooting for europe yeah you'd
like to see europe
yeah yeah
it's like a japanese rugby team at one
point where there were less japanese
place than there were actually
foreign imports exactly and uh this year
in league like the jet there was a
japanese team that qualified for the
main event and that's the first time the
first time i ever happened in history
because no one in japan gives a [ __ ]
about league of legends so this like
really small [ __ ] team qualified for
the main event and i'm just like [ __ ] it
this is the anime plotline right here
what the [ __ ] why am i watching anime i
think it's got a strong niche here but
it just struggles because there's not a
big pc culture here no no unfortunately
and i i don't really see a pc culture
taking off anytime it's growing but it's
i don't think it's like dedicated to
games like lee yeah i think it's just
mobile gaming is just too massive here
it is yeah um for like people because as
we said people don't have time but like
stuff like apex is blowing up so i think
yeah that's been a real big push for pc
i think apex is like v-tubers so yeah
yeah apex is doing very well and v tube
is only just especially at least in
japan very much pushed it yeah i think
because i think before that like the
biggest pc game we had here was like pub
g [ __ ] oh yeah yeah but and like that
was like the best in the dirt and i
think that was like the biggest it had
ever gotten in japan in terms of like a
pc game oh pc like bangs are popping up
a bit in japan they are
pc cafe gaming cafes
because we had them in london but there
was one um and it was so goddamn
expensive yeah yeah it was like 15 an
hour what yeah and it was it's like
it's it's i understand that you you know
you're a business you got to make money
and london real estate isn't cheap but
also you know that it has to come up
maybe a reasonable amount i've got a pc
at home yeah come on like five bucks an
hour i'll buy food i promise i'll buy
food you know
you know i i i don't yeah yeah yeah
seems like a bit of a rip it's a bit too
much because yeah if i want to have a
full gaming session with the boys in the
cafe yeah i spent like a hundred bucks
yeah right yeah and bro i can what if i
want to play like what about the entire
steam library for that yeah what if i
want to play like a game of like civ 2
which is like 12 hours
of rip then
yeah i think in countries like korea
it's a lot more affordable because they
rely more on like you buying food and
drinks and stuff which i would prefer
i'll buy food and drink if yeah exactly
because i feel like in the uk it's like
it's it's a it's a strange concept you
know it is yeah in korea it's just a
normal way to socialize yeah well yeah i
noticed that in korea it was uh north
korea in the uk uh it was either uh
chinese students who were there all day
yeah it was kind of like uh british
people who would be like oh we'll play
pc for an hour
oh get gaming outside the house
switch is it like the switch on mario
kart
of it wasn't meant to
unless you're a rich foreign student i
don't think you should be there all day
exactly
so
it's a shame really because i would i
would love to game in a pcb that's
that's why that's why we want to go to
korea yeah i mean
we've been saying this before and just
takes but we've always just wanted to
spend like 12 hours a day gaming in a
that's my idea of vacation sounds good
sounds like an amazing vacation to me
turn off my phone just game yeah look at
me just game
just get some toxic gaming in there yeah
because i i realized how like small
like how unpopular pc gaming was in
japan when i actually joined the
japanese league of legend servers and i
was just like great join a japanese
league legend servers perfect way to
practice my japanese and game at the
same time yeah a little did i realize
until like about like 50 games in no one
on the japanese league of legends
service speaks japanese no it's all
chinese everyone speaks chinese or
english right because no one japanese is
playing the japanese service ever it's
just like chinese chinese people
smurfing on
chinese people just go to like have fun
yeah
and what i realized is that it's the
most toxic server in the world that i've
been to and that's because no one
japanese is playing yeah
it's so it's all smurfs from other
countries just like
just like being toxic on the server
um so yeah i can see why japanese like
especially with league at least why it
wasn't so popular in japan
apex is a different deal but uh
basically the secret to getting a game
popular in japan i guess is just to
appeal to vichy
just put some gotcha in him
put some gotcha in league and you're all
good you've got the japanese market hell
yeah yeah it's a good social game as
well it's very easy to hop in and just
play a few games
if you ever guys want to you know yeah
one day one i saw you playing minecraft
the other day now yeah exactly yeah i'm
i'm
so disappointed you start without me
what do you mean i was invited you guys
didn't ask me come on
boys
i saw you dying in the lava like five
times listen we don't talk about it yeah
yeah we'll play minecraft